Two weeks ago you and I voted. What, you didn’t
feel my cursor right there next to yours?
Heheh.
Welp, the winner is… (imitating drums)…
BADAAH! K-k-keep ‘em separated.
This was TRICKY. 65% of click voters want
two separate channels but 80% of commen'ers
want just one! That's "commenTers", not "commoners". (Tongue twisted.)
After re-scrutinizing those YouTube notes and chatting with pookums about your collective happiness, my personal creative
pursuits will move off to a new channel opening
November 7! Look for a video invitation then!
But enough distractions, next Friday we’re
back to language in a Halloween special.
(Excuse me, something in my throat there.
Uuuhm...)
So subscribe if you haven’t! And send in
any good fan art that might fit this picture
frame here.